[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
December 8th we are going to celebrate
the best in video games and see what's
next at the game awards which streams
live from the Microsoft theater in Los
Angeles yes there will be new games to
announce the game awards Orchestra will
return and there are many other
surprises in the works but today it's
all about revealing the nominees across
more than 30 categories including of
course game of the year as selected by
our Global jury of more than 100 media
Outlets remember you can help select the
winners by voting at the game awards.com
and on our game awards Discord server
who's in the running well it's my honor
to announce this year's distinguished
nominees for best performance the
nominees for 2022 are
Ashley Birch Horizon forbidden West
Charlotte McBurney a plague tale Requiem
Christopher Judge God of War Ragnarok
man engage immortality and sunny souljic
God of War Ragnarok
in the category of best multiplayer the
nominees are
Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2.
multiversis
OverWatch 2
Splatoon 3
and Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
Shredder's revenge
for best ongoing game the nominees are
Apex Legends
destiny 2.
Final Fantasy 14.
fortnite
and gentian impact the nominees for best
art direction are
Elden ring
God of War Ragnarok
Horizon forbidden West
scorn
and stray for best score and music the
nominees are Olivier de Rivera a plague
tale requiem
bear McCreary God of War Ragnarok two
feathers metal helsinger and yasunori
mitsuda Xenoblade Chronicles 3. the best
audio design nominees are Call of Duty
Modern Warfare 2 Elden ring
God of War Ragnarok
Gran Turismo 7 and Horizon forbidden
West
Innovation and accessibility recognizes
games that are making our industry
available and enjoyable to more people
selected by a special Committee of
accessibility experts the nominees are
as dusk Falls
God of War Ragnarok
return to Monkey Island
The Last of Us Part One
and the Quarry for best narrative the
nominees are a plague tale Requiem Eldon
ring God of War Ragnarok
Horizon forbidden West and immortality
games for impact recognizes a
thought-provoking game with a profound
pro-social meaning the nominees this
year are
a memoir blue
as dusk Falls
citizen sleeper
endling Extinction is forever hindsight
and I was a teenage EXO colonist
for best independent game the nominees
are
Cult of the Lamb
neon white
Seafood
stray and tuning for best mobile game
the nominees are
Apex Legends mobile
Diablo immortal
gentian impact
Marvel snap
Tower of fantasy best community support
presented by Discord recognizes a game
for outstanding support transparency and
responsiveness to players our nominees
are
Apex Legends
destiny 2.
Final Fantasy 14 fortnite
and no man's Sky okay now it's time for
one of my favorite categories Best debut
in the game which recognizes the
development team that made its first
game in 2022 and clearly they hit it out
of the park the nominees are
neon white
Norco
stray
tunic
and vampire survivors for best VR AR
game the nominees are
after the fall
Among Us VR
bone lab
Moss book 2
and red matter too for content creator
of the year the nominees are
Carl Jacobs Ludwig
Rebellion
no Brew
and cutie Cinderella the nominees for
best action game are
Bayonetta 3.
Modern Warfare 2 neon white
sifu
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles Shredder's
revenge
the best action-adventure game nominees
are a plague tale Requiem God of War
Ragnarok Horizon forbidden West
stray and tunic for best RPG the jury
selected Eldon ring
live alive
Pokemon Legends Arceus triangle strategy
and Xenoblade Chronicles 3. the best
fighting game nominees are dnf duel
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure the King of
Fighters 15
multiversus and sifu what's the most
anticipated upcoming game remember these
have to be games that are officially
announced the nominees are
Final Fantasy 16.
Hogwarts Legacy
Resident Evil 4. Starfield
and The Legend of Zelda tears of the
Kingdom this year there's a new category
at TGA best adaptation which recognizes
excellence in authentically creating
shows movies and other creative
Endeavors based on video game worlds and
characters here are first ever nominees
for best adaptation Arcane League of
Legends cyberpunk Edge runners
the cuphead show
Sonic the Hedgehog 2.
and Uncharted next up best family game
the nominees are Kirby and the Forgotten
land Lego Star Wars the Skywalker Saga
Mario and Rabbids Sparks of Hope
Nintendo switch Sports and Splatoon 3.
the best Sim strategy nominees are Dune
spice Wars
Mario and Rabbids Sparks of Hope
Total War Warhammer 3.
2 point campus
and Victoria 3. this year these five
games are nominated for best sports
racing f122
FIFA 23 NBA 2K 23.
Gran Turismo 7
and Ollie Ollie world next up we're
looking at our five Esports categories
starting with best Esports game and the
nominees are Counter-Strike Global
Offensive
DotA 2.
League of Legends
rocket League
and valorant your best Esports athlete
nominees are chuvi
faker
Kerrigan
simple
and yay here are the five nominees for
best Esports team dark zero Esports FaZe
Clan
Genji
La thieves
and Loud the best Esports coach nominees
are blade
bazooka
Doom Bros
Robin
and score the nominees for best Esports
event are Evo
the League of Legends World Championship
pgl major Antwerp the MSI and valorent
champions and now our final two
categories for best game Direction which
recognizes outstanding Creative Vision
and Innovation and game Direction and
design the nominees are Elden ring
God of War Ragnarok
Horizon forbidden West immortality
and stray
and finally on behalf of the jury
comprised of more than
and I know who I am get ready to meet 50
individuals who represent the bright
bold and inclusive future of gaming the
TGA future class presented by Old Spice
coming December 8th to the game awards
know who I am